bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france
l'agencé régionale de santé tire donc la
sonnette d'alarmé
elle envisage des jours difficiles c'est
l'on comprend bien ce communiqué quels
sont aujourd'hui les options
envisageables envisagée par la grèce
pour éviter justement l'effondrement du
système hospitalier
ah bah non je ne suis pas du tout dans
l'est dans les secrets des décisions de
la rs là c'est la déprogrammation
clairement parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre
de vie c'est la déprogrammation de
certaines des interventions non urgentes
pour pouvoir
réorienter du personnel paramédical
l'air les services accueillant des
patients comme il est américain n'est
pas beaucoup d'autres solutions
vous savez pour former un réanimateur il
faut dix ans pour
former une infirmière de réanimation et
en faut 5 donc c'est pas en un coup de
baguette magique qu'on va transformer
les hôpitaux là on en était au bricolage
pour pour arriver à absorber la vague
des hôpitaux qui manquent d'heuliez
alors que
voilà ça fait maintenant deux ans que la
france est confrontée à cette crise
sanitaire comment finalement expliqué
que jusqu'ici rien n'a été fait dans les
hôpitaux pour augmenter la capacité
d'accueillir des malades mais un petit
peu ce que je viens vous dire c'est à
dire que augmenté délit faire des hôtels
c'est pas très compliqué mais encore
faut-il qu'ils aient des soignants pour
s'occuper des malades et s'est soigné on
les a peints et on ne les a pas mais
c'est le résultat de politiques
successives de différents gouvernements
depuis plus de plus d'une dizaine
d'années voire plus donc c'est celle
vraiment le fruit d'une politique
vis-à-vis de l'hôpital qui est que l'on
voit maintenant désastreuse et qui s'est
creusé au fil du temps depuis les
décennies tant l'initiale et qui ont été
aggravés au pire au fil du temps puis
maintenant mais ça y est on prend
conscience que avoir un hôpital qui
marche c'est c'est important mais comme
je vous disais ça ne se répare pas en
quelques mois ni même un nom ni même
deux ans cc des proches et des
programmes sur un minimum de 15 ans la
france qui a enregistré un nouveau
record de cas de contamination hier plus
de deux cent trente deux mille nouveaux
cas
à l'hôpital la situation
d'aujourd'hui est ce qu elle ressemble
finalement à la première vague
va y ressembler elle va y ressemble et
puisque mécaniquement plus ya de cas
plus d'europe cas graves et donc plus il
y aura de cas nécessitant une
hospitalisation et donc le système
hospitalier aura les plus grandes
difficultés à absorber alors ya une
vraie différence quand même avec la
première max est maintenant est un
vaccin
est donc effectivement sur les 230
milles et bientôt 250 mille voire plus
le cas journalier il faut distinguer
deux profils à millas le profil des
personnes protégées par axel qui peuvent
être porteurs pour certains d'entre eux
du virus et ils sont comptabilisés dans
les chiffres que vous venez de citer
mais eux ne risquent pas en très peu de
forme par et puis vous avez une deuxième
catégorie de population qu'ils sont et
non vaccinés mais mal vaccinés qui eux
vont devant l hôpital vont animations et
sont à risque de baisser et donc c'est
ce sont ces patients-là qui pose un
problème pour le bétail
des patients qui sont parfois vacciner
avec deux voire trois doses
peuvent également contracté le
le virus du porc vite 19 on parle
aujourd'hui du variant omicron que l'on
juge beaucoup plus contagieux mais moins
dangereux est ce que dans les services
voilà de réadmission à l'hôpital ce sont
des passants qui sont atteints du
variant delta en majorité qui sont
aujourd'hui malades
pour l'instant c'est le destin belloumi
qu'on veut prendre la place bien entendu
le puisqu'il ya toujours un décalage
entre les petits espaces en population
générale et ce qui se passe à l'hôpital
une grossièrement une dizaine de jours
elle donc le jeu c'est plutôt à la mi
janvier le conte est rapport pas
constater ce qui est les resultats dormi
content si je peux parler comme ça
maintenant
effectivement vous avez dit que loïc on
était beaucoup plus contagieux c'est
totalement vrai ou alors selon les
études selon les estimations ça va de 3
6 fois plus contagieux et selon les
personnes
cc c'est donc une contagiosité
considérablement plus importante en ce
qui concerne la dangerosité pour
l'instant c'est très très incertain et
il ne faut pas compter sur un quelconque
pouvoir patauge est moins important de
ce virus et surtout pas en tirer un
alibi pour lever des mesures barrières
étaient là patinage à la vaccination le
chef de l'état a insisté encore une fois
hier soir pour se demander aux français
de se faire vacciner pour l'instant
c'est la seule arme
fiable est possible pour pour affronter
cette épidémie ou où en est on du côté
du traitement contre le coc u19 à l'eau
pour l'instant très sincèrement aucun
traitement
en dehors des progrès que l'on fait dans
les techniques de réanimation
mais aucun traitement dirigés contre le
virus et encore moins contre au mic on a
montré la qualité significative donc
effectivement il ya des pistes mais pour
l'instant sur le marché il n'y a pas de
traitement
significativement ucas entre contre le
variant au micro c'est très clair
merci beaucoup aux gens pas le talent
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues au
chu de grenoble